welcome to this video round nine of
their candidates tournament and this
video is about the game mamedyarov
playing white against Ronan playing
black if we remember the first round of
the tournament or the first turn the
first lack of the tournament with
Aronian white against no media off we
had this funny game where the chair of
Queen was strapped so the loss for
Momiji are off in the first part of it
let's see what happened in this game
momager of playing d4 and we could
expect this move suddenly
yeah and a momager off goes 493 and now
in the names Oh which wrong am in fact
plays yeah and now he goes for a very
sharp continuation f3 the a very sharp
maybe I'm exaggerating a bit it's an
interesting move
certainly that leads to leads to complex
plane it very much depends on blacks
move now what kind of middle game we get
it can be exceptionally sharp but it can
also be very strategic in nature in the
book that I'm currently writing about
the news oh my recommendation for black
actually is the move c5 and then I'm
going with this
gambit continuation it's a quite an
interesting way to play but not what
Aronian had in mighty went for another
line he played castles in the World
Championship match between honor and
castle there was defiled played yeah
they had this position which is also
sharp in a way but a little bit more
strategical compared to many other lines
yeah castles being played yeah this is
in fact an interesting and maybe
somewhat underrated move it has been
under cloud for ages and only in the
last couple of years it was established
that distance indeed a very playable
line
yeah White has two main moves now he's
got the movie for all the move a three
in fact I always thought that he for has
somewhat risky but nobody off played it
anyway a three is the alternative which
leads to positions that can easily arise
from the same each variation something
that the viewers of my channel might be
familiar with as I'm playing it quite
often goodie form before was played ok
aronia now play d5 this is the idea of
this move castles to basically allow e4
and then immediately attack the center
with d5 here why turn has more than one
option we can push e5 can exchange on d5
in this game he pushed he frightened and
then took on on d5 yeah this is very
normal and here in fact is the first
major crossroads white can play a three
I can play the move f4 f4 is also
possible move blacks idea is of course
to quickly attack the center it leads to
very sharp plane where very often black
gets very decent play on the light
squares note that these pawns are all on
dark squares and therefore the light
squares and whites can were somewhat
weakened like those and the bishop might
come out mostly to f5 actually a very
sharp position but my major of played a
three this is yeah similar but it has a
very distinct difference that is that
there is no pawn on f4 which is very
important the dark square Bishop is
actually not hindered by a pawn and this
will in fact be an important factor in
the game yeah BC was played and now F
my Iranian mother yah had already taken
some time maybe he didn't expect castles
this line is not so popular okay
f6 the wide center is being attacked and
yeah what should white play here yeah
you don't really want to play a forum
this is answered by the capture and what
is White's next move
yeah if you consider this not this will
not end well check and we have this
typical check procedure if white moves
the King check he will lose this Bishop
yeah you cannot maintain your Center so
it was taken on f6 yeah and here Aronian
introduces a new idea quite remarkable
idea actually the absolute main line
here and played quite often it's just to
recap join f6 and mostly they do it with
the Queen the reason is why would the
Queen if you take with the night it's
not totally terrible but the knight is
not so well placed his main hair square
so that he looks at are controlled by
this f3 pawn and in fact after that this
is what a ruin played sorry after the
Queen capture very often we get this
type of position both nights here and
then Bishop to a5 black has very decent
play on the light squares I think this
position is perfectly acceptable for
black butter only exactly is a very
sharp continuation Queen e8 shaken yeah
what's the point really white now played
Queen e2 and now he played Queen to f7 a
very interesting concept the Queen
switches over to f7 and allows a quick
rupee ad and of course white has
absolutely no development and the queen
is
on the same file as as the king so why
doesn't a somewhat tricky situation here
but it's not clear how how promising
this really is for black we see that
here mamedyarov just took on g7 in
somewhat greedy move certainly but he
already has in a way screwed up his
position so much that you need to get a
pawn for it and to be honest this is not
just a pawn the problem is that black
also needs to invest time to actually
take it and maybe sometimes it's even
the case that white can't keep it you
know like with this and if you can
maintain a pawn on the seventh rank yeah
well any endgame for example would be a
winning for what yeah okay let's go to
concrete line this is more importantly
anyway rook e8 and okay that's easy
there should be three don't want to give
away the Queen and now Knight to c6 so
we have a really crazy position if we do
a pawn count White has seven points
well black only has five so black has at
the moment sacrificed two pawns
certainly the determine pawn is
something that you can can take back but
it cost smooth and it's not clear that
you actually have the time to do that
and in the long run blacks King is also
tricky short-term though blacks position
looks excellent if you consider that
this is really a big traffic jam on the
e-file very critical situation for white
White has no development and like can
easily use the Knights to go to c4 um in
fact the next couple of moves very much
forced Queen d2 plate by mayara off I
think this is the only move really
because you need to get both pieces the
Queen and the king out of the e-file and
we have this side step and the King to
f2 next
there is really nothing else that you
can do um yeah aronia play tonight a
five yeah now no simply no time to waste
yeah threatens to win an exchange and
Dwight must react to that it could be
one and now night to be six and we see
that black really has a serious
initiative for the for the sacrifice
material this is just a very annoying
threat so uh it's black already better
yeah it seems that what only has one
playable move and this is what not a jar
of plate playbook to before and the idea
is quite simple you need to sacrifice an
exchange on c4 and well it's it's the
only move as well it's not like a
brilliant sacrifice it's just what you
what you needed to do
yeah in this position Aronian played the
move Knight to c4 yeah which is
basically grabbing the exchange the
thing is what else is there black it
actually had a decent alternative and
this is with the move c5 this is an
interesting way to to play it yeah white
mistake no debate and now going to see
form so what has happened here it's a
comparable to the game but black has
flicked in this c5 needs to really break
up the center yeah Knight on c4 yeah
white has no choice you need to take
this of course Knight takes this yeah
how to evaluate this position yeah we
can maybe add a further movement 92
seems very logical and Bishop to a5 yeah
I actually have a hard time to really
evaluate that if we continue something
like that for example king of two Bishop
to d3 Knight f4 and let's say rook the
AIDS
and Bishop deform just to show what what
I'm talking about in this situation we
have a position where white is an
exchange down but he has got a couple of
pawns and he's got this very strong g7
pawn which is protected by the bishop in
this complete position there may be his
rook takes d4 anyway but what I'm trying
to get it is some that white has very
strong remaining pieces the bishop on d4
which in fact only was made possible by
black actually playing c5 and Edward
capture if you don't flick that in their
support on d4 and the bishop is not able
to go that quickly and the white has
this strong knight which possibly can
join the action at the right moment on
the other hand there is rookie to know
which white needs to to look for and
general speaking White's King is also
not very secure blacks King is
potentially bad now but it's also not
clear Hawaii would organize a very
direct attack in the near future it
shows that the positions are terribly
complex that arise I'm not sure that c5
is really better than what was played
but it is certainly an interesting idea
aronia played this directly and after
the capture however he avoided to gain
the exchange interestingly enough he
took with the pawn his idea was that he
will get the exchange anyway and he
probably intended to do it in a way with
with a gain of a temple maybe but it
does not really work out that way I
think the easiest to play was certainly
Knight takes e4 takes takes and yeah now
probably 92 need to develop at some
point and let's say Bishop f5 and Bishop
to f4 with the idea to get it to e5 and
again we have a position where
at least to me the situation is not
clear at all maybe at some point black
should take the pawn let's say here just
for argument's sake and yeah we should
be five liquid probably secretary
exchanged castles first maybe castles
first and then maybe Knight g3 and
Bishop e5 I really think that White has
a very decent position here the
remaining pieces are all quite good the
knight will join on the King side and
the dark squared Bishop has potentially
as a potential to get really monster
piece on e5 just imagine a bishop here
supported by four this is simply
unbearable for black with the bed King
position yeah probably something like
that was some what what was what needed
only needed to play he took with the
pawn which is not bad in itself but I
think it leads to a position that is
very similar but still somewhat worse in
comparison yeah Bishop rook b5 which is
strong again he wants to again sacrifice
the exchange for a knight on d5 white
also could play 92 - after this
sacrifice possibly by playing the Bishop
to h6 but in comparison I think this is
this is worse this is especially
annoying something like that and I think
black is quite okay here but it's still
unclear very unlikely in this position
rook b5 is I think better now Bishop f5
was played there also was the immediate
95 which might probably a transpose a
mistake and play here and it's again
this type of position where White has
two pawns this strange pawn on g7 and
the long-term idea that blacks King will
never really find a safe place on the
board yeah this was played bishop
five yeah here Mahmoud yaar of plate and
king f2 very understandable move the
computer simply loves rookie five
blocking this action on the e-file and
avoiding the loss of of the exchange I'm
not I'm not 100% sold on the idea it's
probably not bad but I'm not sure how
good it is really black can play
something like that for example and
claim that this is no advantage to have
the pawn on e5 but okay it's certainly
not a bad position
this is this mantra I'm sure of a white
and I'd say f4 what exactly is blacks
idea now maybe Queen e7 roopd 8 this
might be an idea this is a very murky
this type of position but I mean what is
this right from material point of view
six pawns yeah Black has tried to
justify a pawn sacrifice IAM and with
this King long term I really don't
believe it
maybe rookie 5 was was an improvement on
mama dr.oz play but what he body did was
not bad so that's that I'm pretty sure
of yeah well now 95 he wanted to get the
exchange back it's simply that this
Bishop is detect and where do you want
to go with it yeah he just he just took
the night which is very sensible I guess
and the thing is look at this position
now white really has some serious
prospects to get both pieces here into
into the attack against the King more
White's Kings relatively said from
material point of view this is also
quite okay for white he's got as
mentioned he has got seven points
against five points two points and
blacks King is always a liability in
fact if we look at this and look at the
initial position of this whole line
where
Jayan played this this new concept it's
very much clear that he aimed for this
type of position look look at his
clocked run and played all this
relatively quickly so he went for this
deliberately and note that here he also
could have played a simple move like
like Queen takes no not now Queen takes
f6 so where he really went for the
sharpest possible line and a new line
that he had prepared at home and looking
at this position I'm really not sure if
this was such a great practical idea I
mean mommy giraffe is known to be a very
sharp and creative player in
unconventional positions and yeah maybe
it would have been would have been
easier for Aronian to just play Queen f6
and play a somewhat more positional game
trying to to tailor the game more to two
Aronian zone strengthless with mainly
Bly in my opinion with being a very
creative positional player he's played
some amazing strategical concepts that
really no other player could have come
up with very very impressive games at
times and it's it's not so often in
those complicated positions where
there's very unequal materialists work
very often from from starting with
symmetrical positions where you simply
inject so much life with interesting
ideas that it actually becomes
interesting later so um a question a bit
this this choice of position okay um we
played a5 now and b5 well white is
pushing the edge pawn up the board he's
simply banking on the fact that black
does not dare to take the pawn because
this leads to direct the teching ideas
but on the other hand if white manages
to put to push a pawn up to h6 you're
never going to get those pawns
any type of endgame is probably lost and
well the thing is what is blacks
counterplay no Aronian try to to open up
on the on the queenside
with this and this might still be okay
but it gets very very tricky soon the
eyes took now 2 x and t a plate coming
to be 5 and this seems to be not so
accurate
maybe you should go Bishop III here a
possible line could be your watch it
should probably move the knight this is
an important attacking piece of Knight
f4 is interesting but also Knight c3 and
something like that Knight c3 Queen to
d6 and white probably will push h6 yeah
like it takes this pawn and well this
position is completely completely murky
I have no idea what's going on the
computer is liking white slightly but in
a practical game anything can happen
really white has this amazing port
configuration but how concrete is it
actually I'm going to get in terms of
attacking black skin those pieces are
not quite near the king and how do you
continue here maybe rook e1 what has a
good location but it can it can be very
very dramatically
I can end very very dramatically in
short order looks like that looks
completely normal but what about that
check and Knight f6 is actually
impossible to prevent you can take here
data dad gets a queen in the meantime
it's very very tough but probably what
what you needed to play 93 you played a
queen to be 5
and now we are played rookie one here he
had a very interesting alternative in
pushing d5 this was probably quite a
good option for white that is that this
d5 pawn will be covered by Knight f4 for
instance in this move order and white is
putting this bishop on d4 next and well
this is a very strong piece 1.d4 yeah so
it's very very complicated I'm not
saying that white is winning flat but it
will be tricky for black let's say Queen
a6 intending to enter here okay I go age
five and this is my idea
Knight at the end to f6 Bishop to d4
Knight h5 9f six and it's just winning
this is not easy at all would like to
defend and if everything else fails and
maybe can just take on d3 at some stage
I don't really like it to be honest I
would be very very very display qiyam
the other computer also likes white very
much but in a practical game it's it's
hard to tell
yeah rook e1 was played by a momager of
maybe not the the toughest move but I
think white is by now really in good
shape yeah after that yeah after d5 it's
probably over it's very hard to
determine where our own Ian's mistake
really was maybe it was it was Miss time
to to push with before that quickly
maybe it was one problem with this is
that in the in this type of after this
type of transformation of the pawn
structure what actually gets in this d5
idea which is super important to get the
bishop to deform what I'm pretty sure of
is that that this now is this basically
lost for black the ideas really it is
long it is this bishop moves h6 and the
knight to f6 and
you really I don't see what the black is
doing a very interesting point in all
this is that this Bishop a black which
is sitting in the middle of White's
position is somewhat superfluous peace
its operating on light squares and the
whole play by why this is running on
dark squares
it's simply pointing into thin air
mostly and this is also reason why
White's position is so strong in a way
because his tech which age six with age
six yeah I first put the King yeah no
worries
and then this trade and now we have all
the pieces in there tech well this piece
it could also be off the bots it's no
difference at all as it does not happen
defense at the moment
okay Queen to d7 and here I think Mahmud
Yara from calculated things to the end
and very nicely played aged six first
yeah you want you want to go here Queen
f7 to prevent that and now he plays it
anyway a very nice move it wasn't the
only winning move this I need to need to
point out but it's it's very nice if
black node takes check check we have a
very quick mate yeah he went back check
and now Queen e8 yeah very cute yeah
Queen sacrifice is a bit much but it's
very a very nice finishing finishing
touch like took it only move can I have
six check King f7 only move and Knight
exceed yeah well obviously black cannot
take as I can voting immediately and
yeah what why just threatens Knight f6
back and then g8 and well black only can
do that the only possible move after
which Aronian played Knight f6 he had
calculated this to the very end
what you can do here is vidas you can
play b5 as well which is also very
convincing win but what he did is
perfectly sufficient and also totally
forced g8 mate not made but g8 Queen
so like must cover that and here yeah
just promoted because he had evaluated
this endgame King to f4 and really this
is nothing that black can do in this
position Aronian resigned they have an
opposite color bishops and came with two
extra pawns and the problem is simply
that this is too much white will easily
get a position where he has passes that
are very far apart and we had this idea
already earlier in the tournament with
the passers a and H pawn trying to
remember what game it was it I think it
was similar to Paulo and well here it is
just too much I can put put some moves
on the board too
to show let's say c2 and now white
pushes his pawns jump where'd you go
yeah okay
I still have the b-pawn yeah I know what
we'll get the C pawn and now easily win
you can also just attack this here it's
it's too much
I mean opposite colored bishops and game
are very often drawn but if one side has
too many passed pawns it's yeah well
it's it's just lost opposite colors
bishops doesn't do not matter if it's if
it's too much material and especially
with passed pawns so another very tough
result him from one of the leaders
Aronian lost this game against mahadji
Arif which means that mamedyarov is back
on 50% he is from minus one to five
80% and of course Aronian who was on +2
before the round is now back to being on
just on a plus one squad winning more
game than losing he lost two games and
won three losing two games as pretty
much in this type of format if only
first place counts so a very very tough
result for the minion top player and
pre-tournament
favorite yeah I think this game is a bit
of an example where someone yeah it's
sort of being killed by the own by the
mess that she has had introduced himself
by this new opening concept which is
certainly interesting I mean this is a
kind of also kind of a case of hindsight
is always 20/20
yeah well afterwards you know that maybe
I should have done something less
forcing you want to get in your
interesting ideas but I think the
resulting position simply fitted mama
Dee are very well he played an excellent
game here and maybe it would have been
from a psychological point of view been
better to get a sort of more complicated
strategical battle instead of such a
dynamic position but as mentioned
hindsight is always 20/20 okay I hope
you enjoyed this coverage and well it's
going to be very tough for aronia nifty
Aronian fan you need to really keep your
fingers crossed you will need yeah
probably two wins at least two to do
something note that he always has the
worst tiebreak compared to to the Sheep
alright thanks for watching